ahmadiyya tahar is 13 years old
earlier this month she weighed just 11
kilograms
she arrived at this hospital in sana'a
in desperate need of treatment for acute
malnutrition
the reason she was so poorly fed is
because we have no income no work
no assistance from organizations or the
united nations we are displaced
her family couldn't afford the journey
to hospital so they asked friends and
neighbors to help raise
funds
[Music]
the reason she has malnutrition is
because we don't have food or anything
else
her father has passed away we don't have
anything and because of this
sometimes she doesn't eat
a lack of food and other traumas nearly
killed tahar
but her case is not unique
the u.n says 400 thousand children in
yemen could die from starvation this
year
if they don't get help but the head of
the malnutrition ward at this hospital
says offering help is getting harder
we cannot cope with the health situation
there are severe shortages and supplies
and the treatments needed in
examinations
everything we asked the united nations
and other aid organizations to help lift
the blockade as soon as possible
severe acute malnutrition means there is
a risk of death from lack of food
aiden hadeida among the worst hit areas
and are closed off from receiving
international aid because of increased
regional fighting and a global pandemic
nearly half of the aid that was expected
this year hasn't come through
even when families manage to get their
sick children to hospital
sometimes it's too late
with most of these patients they need
two or three days of travel to be able
to reach the hospital in sanaa
so their conditions worsen by the time
they reach the hospital
and we usually expect complications
taher has gained weight since being
admitted but has a long recovery ahead
while famine has never been officially
declared in yemen the u.n
continues to warn that it's close leah
harding al jazeera